love makes your soul crawl out of its
hiding place
true love stories never have endings
there is only one happiness in this life
to love and be loved
love is something Sent From Heaven to
worry the hell out of you
the only thing we never get enough of or
give enough of is love
[Music]
true love comes quietly without banners
or flashing lights
if you hear bells get your ears checked
to love and be loved is to feel the Sun
from both sides
life is the flower for which love is the
honey
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength while loving someone deeply
gives you courage
you always gain by giving love
[Music]
recognizes no barriers
love is composed of a single soul
inhabiting two bodies
foreign
we are most alive when we are in love
there is no charm equal to tenderness of
heart
the heart has its reasons of which
reason knows nothing
love is friendship that has caught fire
if you find someone you love in your
life hang on to that person
thank you
a simple I love you means more than
money
is better to have loved and lost than
never to have loved at all
[Music]
to be brave is to love someone without
expecting anything in return
you know you're in love when you can't
fall asleep because reality is better
than your dreams
the best thing to hold on to in life is
each other
love is the flower you've got to let it
grow
[Music]
love is an endless Act of forgiveness
at the touch of love everyone becomes a
poet
[Music]
when we love we always strive to become
better than we are when we strive to
become better than we are everything
around us becomes better
to feel the love of people who we love
is a fire that feeds our life
sometimes it's a form of love just to
talk to somebody that you have nothing
in common with and still be fascinated
by their presence
[Music]
your task is not to seek love but merely
to seek and find all the barriers within
yourself that you have built against it
when you love someone you love the
person as they are not as you'd like
them to be
[Music]
the greatest thing you'll ever learn is
to love and be loved in return
quiet love can drown out any fear
you don't love someone because they're
perfect you love them in spite of the
fact that they're not
to love is to recognize yourself in
another
when you realize you want to spend the
rest of your life with somebody you want
the rest of your life to start as soon
as possible
[Music]
when there is great love there are
miracles
[Music]
passion makes the world go round love
just makes it a safer place
foreign
Are Meant To Be Loved not to be
understood
you know it's love when all you want is
for that person to be happy even if
you're not part of their happiness
love is the magician that pulls man out
of his own hat
lots of people want to ride with you in
a limo but what you want is someone who
will take the bus with you when the limo
breaks down
continued to share your heart with
people even if it is broken
[Music]
there is always some Madness in love
but there is also some reason to the
madness
Love is Like the Wind you can't see it
but you can feel it
[Music]
love has nothing to do with what you
expect to get only with what you are
expecting to give which is everything
foreign
time seems to move slower and when you
are falling in love with someone
time seems to be moving faster
it is a curious thought but it is only
when you see people looking ridiculous
that you realize just how much you love
them
[Music]
in the end we discover that to love and
let go can be the same thing
the pleasure of Love lasts but a moment
the pain of Love lasts a lifetime
love is a thing that is full of cares
and fears
a purpose of human life no matter who is
controlling it is to love whoever is
around to be loved
romance is the glamor that turns the
dust of everyday life into a golden Haze
[Music]
love is the strange bewilderment which
overtakes one person on account of
another person
one word frees us of all the weight and
pain of life
that word is love
it is better to be hated for what you
are than to be loved for what you are
not
let the beauty of what you love be what
you do
[Music]
love is the ultimate expression of the
will to live
only true love can fuel the hard work
that awaits you
[Music]
love all trust few do wrong to none
[Music]
a life lived in love will never be dull
love is shown more in Deeds than in
words
the love we give away is the only love
we keep
[Music]
trust your intuition and be guided by
love
[Music]
he is not a lover who does not love
forever
never love anyone who treats you like
your ordinary
[Music]
a man is already halfway in love with
any woman who listens to him
foreign
someone you can live with you marry
someone you cannot live without
[Music]
[Music]